Could we have done the same thing with a loop over here? Not really because in
this loop we didn't traverse all of the pictures, we skipped the zeroth one.
You can only use the enhanced for loop when you look at all of the elements of
an array list. And there's another reason when you use the enhanced for loop
you don't actually know the index value. Of any of the elements. And, over
here, we needed the index value because we had the i-th element, and then the i
minus first element. But, I'll give you a challenge question, and that is, to
rethink the logic of this loop, and rewrite it, as an enhanced for loop, like
this. And to make that a little bit easier, you get to position the first
image, at offset ten. So put ten pixels before the first image, before the
second, before the third, and so on.